we've been using the homepod mini for
over three months now
and during that time we've been testing
it and comparing it to other smart
speakers
like the regular homepod and max
actually got me one of these homepod
minis for christmas
and to be completely honest i wasn't
sure if i was gonna have much use out of
it
because i already have a regular homepod
in my living room
which i absolutely love i've really been
enjoying the homepod mini
and surprisingly one of the things that
we thought was a downside with the mini
actually turned out to be an upside and
i
actually think that this is gonna be a
better buy
instead of the regular homepod for a lot
of you guys out there
and i'm gonna get into that in just a
minute in this long-term review
i'm gonna focus on answering a question
that a lot of you guys might be having
is the homepod mini worth 100
and who should be buying one i want to
start off with our initial impressions
way back
three months ago when we first unboxed a
couple of these minis
and i've gotta say that we were shocked
by the incredibly small size
look at this this thing can fit in the
palm of my hand
on top of that it has shockingly loud
volume
we were not expecting to get that much
volume out of this thing
and the sound quality is really great
especially in the mids and the highs
it's very nice and crisp
but one thing we noticed for sure is
that the bass on the homepod mini
is nowhere near as deep and loud as it
is
on the main homepod so just check out
this sound comparison
[Music]
so as you just heard the mini definitely
doesn't compare to one of the main home
pods
but that kind of makes sense because the
main homepod is three times more
expensive but one of the benefits with
going with this
is that you can get two of these and
connect them as a stereo pair
yes that's left and right audio and they
actually do get
quite loud but surprisingly the single
homepod by itself
does have more bass and it does sound
better
especially at those louder volumes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
but one thing that's really great about
using it as a stereo pair
is that you can connect these to your
smart tv
and basically use two of these as a
smart speaker
system now to be completely honest
these sound so good that i would
recommend using two of these
instead of just some kind of basic sound
bar or some cheap
audio system these are really good for
that now over the past three months
we've been using one of these in our
office and it's been giving us a really
nice music listening experience
the bass is not as deep and loud as the
homepod
but when you're in an office building
like we are you don't want really loud
bass that can be distracting
to other people and to be honest when
you have really loud bass
it can be distracting for us as well
when we're sitting there researching or
editing videos
we don't want to be distracted the thing
that really matters
is the nice clean and crisp sound
quality
and that is what the mini gives you now
going beyond the sound quality
what makes this really nice and worth
the 100 is that it's also a smart
speaker
so at any time we can ask it to play
music or for example
on our iphone or our max we can use
airplay
to stream videos or music to the homepod
minis
and that is extremely convenient because
it works using wi-fi
and any device connected to the same
wi-fi network
can access and control the music even if
you have a guest
so for an office environment like ours
i've got to say that the mini has been
really really great but now i want to
move into my experience at home
since i do have one of these and i've
been using it over the past three months
since i already have a large homepod in
my living room
i was thinking about putting this guy in
the kitchen
however my wife does not like having
extra things on the kitchen counters
so i had to make a compromise because of
the tiny size
i was able to fit this on the kitchen
windowsill
and it's been working perfectly now the
reason i wanted this in the kitchen is
because we have sort of an
l-shaped layout going from the living
room into the kitchen
and sometimes when you're in the kitchen
you can't really hear
the main living room homepod that well
but now when we're washing dishes or
doing anything in the kitchen
we have the mini on the windowsill and
we can hear it clearly and that is just
so much more convenient
now one thing i didn't mention before is
that our house is actually
a duplex so our kitchen wall is actually
shared
with our neighbors so i actually like
that the mini does not have very loud
base
otherwise it would have been really
annoying for the neighbors
and also because of that reason we never
max out the volume on our homepods
so the fact that the mini does not get
quite as loud as the homepod
doesn't really matter to us what really
matters is having nice and clean
sound quality and that is what the
homepod mini offers
but the one thing that i absolutely love
about having two
home pods in my house is that now i can
tell siri
to play a song everywhere and you get
sound in both the kitchen
and the living room and the most
important part is that the sound between
both of them
is always perfectly in sync and now ever
since we got the new mini
the sound quality is really really good
in the dining room
because you have sound coming from the
kitchen and the dining room at the same
time so it's really immersive
and it sounds great so based on all of
that i honestly don't think that i can
go back to just having one
main homepod now that i have the
experience of two of them
and at a price of just a hundred dollars
i would definitely say that the homepod
mini is worth it
because of the awesome and clean sound
quality and even if you already have a
regular homepod like i do
i would definitely say that buying a
mini is worth it especially if you have
a kitchen layout like i do
and one thing i do want to mention is
that we've compared the homepod mini
with other smart speakers like the
amazon echo and the google nest
and our main final conclusion was that
the homepod mini offers
the best balance of price volume and
sound quality so this is definitely a
great deal but in terms of the smart
features
i'd say that the mini is definitely not
the best because siri
honestly doesn't work as well as the
competitors so if you really care about
smart features or having a smart home
i would probably recommend just going
for an amazon echo because it has just
so much
more smart functionality but if you just
want a great
music listening experience with some
extra smart functionality
then i would definitely go for the
homepod mini for
100 so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
long term review and if you did
go ahead and click the like button and
click that circle above for more videos
like this one
and definitely check out our homepod
mini sound comparisons right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you